hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to MLG flappy bird the
greatest game ever made in the history
of mankind and is currently the highest
rated game on gamejolt that's actually
not lie and the one that I've been
looking forward to the most in the whole
wide world
oh boy hibbity bibbity here we go so
okay so so so we're going to be playing
MLG flappy bird which I've actually
played a few times now and I can't help
but admit to say that it was fun so you
will see what I mean
very soon god damnit okay
alright that didn't count I know that
I'm not good at flappy bird just don't
know what to say I had a whole bunch of
jokes lined up and ready to go but here
they are out of my mind but I didn't do
anything it's not time for durood weed
storm that's right I don't you know I
don't even know what I'm going for if
I'm going for a high score or something
but I owe you guys don't mind but I'm
just gonna go and rate this ten out of
ten Doritos Mountain Dew IGN so why do I
care why do I care about losing oh but I
got the Sonic
you can't just not give me the Sonic
after I obviously touched it wait look
all right so what I'm trying to say in
this game is that it's a work of art
beyond everything that humanity has done
in the past I don't even know what the
hell that is supposed to be but it's
beyond uh said x-files or even all of
them it's it's it's art beyond
everything it's art beyond anything that
humanity has ever done and it is shining
example of what gaming can be when indie
game developers when indie game
developers put their minds together what
when it hello
I broke the game I can't click anymore
oh okay
oh hi Luminato okay I'm back now I had
to restart the game cuz I want to keep
playing so so badly
also badly like you wouldn't I hate I
hate hey [ __ ] I hate to admit it god
dammit this game is actually fun I got
the high score but god damn it oh it's
doing good why do I care so much is so
stupid I thought I loved it goddamnit a
gang hate games that make me care is
like presentable Liberty all over again
dammit dammit what [ __ ] me that god damn
it okay so if you want to play this game
you can check the link in the
description below but beware it's only
for MLG pro gamers such as me I've
always said how Pro I am and you are
obviously as pro as you say you are so
keep shouting every day of your life
smoke weed everyday and
and whatever the hell else are saying
that rambling sounds some nonsense just
don't borrow Ripper you bud I got [ __ ]
just out for a rip honey I don't even
know why I'm still playing to this point
I literally have nothing else to say I
tried to make the joke I'm taking this
game seriously but it's completely
impossible and what's worse is I have a
shame that I'm enjoying it yeah you know
what I got one more all right I am put
up god dammit yeah and oh yeah
oh god damn it Sonic you painting me you
bastard you're fast [ __ ]
god damn it [ __ ] god damn it piece of
[ __ ]
I got 215 what can I get back to there
[ __ ] yeah I got the damn it oh god damn
it I was actually concentrating you
screw you god [ __ ] damn it you piece
of [ __ ]
you ain't gonna get me god damn it god
dear okay I'm done all right I'm done
this message is a bad game to the kids
this message is just that if this game
is not giving a good message to the
youth of society it's gonna cause
degradation and decay among the youth
and it's gonna be just bottomed out I'm
done I'm out of here I can't handle any
more I ain't doing it no all right no I
ain't doing it I [ __ ]
no god damn it no way
fashionable the pigs to understand that
I'm on your side but is you know oh my
god come on brother Lu you were they
were